I don't know if people are aware but
your dad's family owns the New York
Giants okay your mom's family owns the
Pittsburgh Steelers and these teams they
don't play each other I don't think on
Thanksgiving but they do play each other
and you have to be in the house
sometimes when your mom's team and not
the team she routes for the team that is
her team is Rudy yes father's team what
do you do what does that like well it
rarely happens very rarely happens but
yes it is happening this coming weekend
but good news is is that we always win
so we're just always happy that's so
funny that you say it that way because
my whole personality is we always lose I
would imagine was it intimidating let's
say you had a met a guy boyfriend you
want to bring him back to the house and
you know it's this big football family
would that be intimidating for her yeah
I did a lot of somehow I ended up dating
a lot of Englishmen which you know most
of that means somehow what is that you
make it sound like they just washed up
on shore
[Applause]
there's an app just for English exactly
yeah well anyway they like soccer not
football yeah so okay oh this is my
boyfriend right now
my boyfriend Jamie is amazing if he
surprised me one day when we first
started dating he spent a night where
all he did was watch all the the
previous season of the Giants there
every game and so the next time we
watched a game together he knew
everything about it which was amazing so
we did his homework he did his homework
but I I was dating someone a long time
ago who came to visit my parents
not too long after the Giants won the
Super Bowl and and the trophy had just
arrived and my parents my mom
specifically was very excited about this
and she she said you know would you like
to see it would you like to hold it
they've they've sent white gloves that
you put on before you can hold the
trophy and so he was a very enthusiastic
man and he put on the gloves and then he
went to lift up the trophy but he lifted
it up from from the base which we didn't
know wasn't connected to the
and it fell and in slow motion I saw he
was wearing these steel toed boots which
he was a pretty good soccer player and
he kicked his foot up and caught it
where he caught the trophy with his boot
and and then caught it in his hands and
he dented just a tiny catch it kick
stopped it he he kicked the they never
hit the ground though and I look over at
my dad who's in the kitchen just
watching the whole thing happened and he
was just like we broke up and that was
it yeah
[Laughter]
you